hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out the brand new poly Voyager
free 60 plus UC earbuds from HP these
come in two different colors there's a
carbon and a white sand and I'm not sure
which color I have so we're gonna have
to open it up and find out I keep saying
get HP for partnering with me on this
video Let's unbox
personalize my experience
poly lens yes I will download it all
right app is downloading we haven't even
unboxed them yet let's get to the
earbuds quick start guide we may need
this information tells us all of the
things we need to know I like that
they're giving step-by-step directions
start here
here's the case you can see the little
LCD on the top we've got two cables we
have a USBC to a 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack a USB a to a USBC and
extra ear tips these will be great
because this will allow you to get a
nice Shore fit depending upon your ear
shape you'll be able to find a size
that's right for you so this is kind of
a thicker case but it is pretty high
tech because it does have this LCD on
the top of it and you're actually able
to control your music basically use this
as a tiny little remote so it looks like
we have the carbon black and I also like
that this gives you a little USB
Bluetooth transmitter so if there is
something that doesn't have Bluetooth
capabilities you're able to insert this
and turn that into something that is
Bluetooth enabled oh these wow this has
like a very premium feel I don't know it
just feels like a more premium plastic
that I'm used to for these types of
earbuds so there's a little button right
here and this button allows you to pause
play answer calls and if if you swipe
it's allow you to adjust the volume you
can also mute and unmute calls and you
can also activate active noise
cancellation and transparency mode it's
time to set them up we have them popped
up right here the board Jeffrey 60 plus
UC open the smart case remove both
earbuds all right okay press okay we're
doing that case is up to date oh my gosh
we are I think we're just about ready
and here they are they are connected so
now I need to figure out which fit is
good for me they've got little L's and
R's on them so for those of you who may
struggle with your left and right like
me so it seems like right now I have the
medium ear tips in and those feel pretty
good so we'll try those out and see how
they work out okay oh there's an update
available let's do our update so now
it's time to do a first listen just to
see what they sound like so here's what
the case looks like while they're
connected I'm going to close this it's
pretty cool because this is actually
acting like a remote I can control the
music I can change how I want the
transparency mode so this is on the
speech mode oh oh I can hear the
environment around me all right let's
play some music for the first time we're
gonna listen to some Imagine Dragons
okay all right
all right so I tested out the music
everything seems to be working my
earbuds are updated now let's go test
these out a little bit more
so this is a new lineup of wireless
earbuds that's designed specifically for
hybrid work with some really cool
features to keep you productive and
connected during video calls and
entertained when you need to take a
break they have adaptive active noise
canceling transparency mode a three mic
array for Next Level voice quality and
the super handy touch screen charging
case now this case will let you remotely
control your earbuds so you can adjust
the volume play and pause media mute
audio switch between Bluetooth devices
and check in on your battery life at a
glance and speaking of battery life the
case can charge the earbuds twice giving
the earbuds a total talk time battery
life of 16 and a half hours which is so
awesome plus they have fast charging
which will get you an hour of talk time
after just 15 minutes of charging the
Voyager earbuds also come with a service
called poly lens Cloud which lets users
personalize their poly device settings
and it lets teams manage and receive
insights from anywhere in the world so
I've been testing these out for a few
days now and the thing that I'm so
obsessed with other that of course the
great sound quality and the ability to
make really crisp clear conference calls
with these microphones this case is so
awesome there's been times where I've
been on runs I've been just walking
around and I'll have the case in my
pocket and for whatever reason I just
feel so inclined to take this out and
adjust the volume switch the tracks that
I'm listening to it's like such a fun
little novelty and I'm obsessed with it
I also do like of course that it does
charge with USBC so I have had some
really great battery life with these and
it's been super fun testing these out
over the past couple of days I like that
these will connect to the app and you
can do all sorts of customizations if I
want to change the swipe I can have that
mute my calls if I'm on a call or if I'm
streaming I can have that turn up the
volume I have been using this as I've
been going into different types of
environments adjusting the noise
cancellation so when I click it right
now it's actually off now you can also
adjust the transparency so you can turn
it off you can do the environment so you
hear a little bit of everything around
you like I just heard that car starting
up and you can change it to transparency
for speech and you can try it off so you
have all of those options right at the
touch of your finger and I'm going to
turn the noise cancellation on so that I
don't have to hear that car
now a big part of what makes these
earbuds really great is that they're
really optimized for doing conference
calls each bud has a three mic array
that triangulates on your voice and
minimizes surrounding noises so you're
always loud and clear as you guys might
know I do a ton of video calls for work
so specifically if that is something
that you are doing a lot of being able
to have that great sound quality not
only from the person on the other end
but having these enhanced microphones
especially having it triangulate on your
voice is so key to make sure that
everyone else on the other end of those
calls is also getting a great experience
so overall I'm really impressed with
these earbuds I think that if you work
in an office or even if you're a
traveling remote worker or sort of
freelancing and On The Go these will be
a really great option for you the sound
quality is really great and they're
super comfortable plus I love this touch
screen on the charging case and I really
think that all earbuds should come with
something like this you guys are
interested in checking these out or
getting more information or
just I will put
a little quality avoid
Voyage don't forget to like this video
And subscribe if you haven't already and
if you have any questions or want to
know anything else about these earbuds
let's chat in the comments until then
I'll see you guys in the next video bye